we need to begin with the child
sacrifice stuff that's a sentence i
didn't i never thought i would say i
didn't hope that i would ever say that
we have it it is
crazy
because
the left
knows not what it does it it doesn't it
it can't see it but but if you're
outside of that bubble if you're outside
of the liberal establishment you look at
this and you think guys you're you are
actually siding with real full-on
satanists and aztec demon gods and you
don't and they say no you don't get it
it's it's so clever oh it's no you don't
unders it's not really
satanists that we're siding with except
it is so here's a representative
article in the hopkins post satanic
temple floats devilishly clever strategy
to dodge the texas abortion law oh it's
devilishly clever what's what is
devilishly clever what are they doing
well
they've got this new strategy they're
going to say that taking an abortion
drug is an important part of their
religious ritual it's a sacrament
in the satanic
temple
quote a lawyer for the
massachusetts-based temple sent a letter
to the food and drug administration
earlier this week to request that the
church be allowed access without
prescription to the abortion-inducing
drugs
nifa pristone and mizo pro stall as part
of its sacramental abortion ritual he
compared employing the drugs to the use
of peyote and certain native american
rituals under the religious freedom
restoration act for the temple bodily
autonomy and science or sacrosanct
and the abortion ritual is an important
expression of those beliefs
explained temple co-founder lucian
greaves who oh how clever wow
gosh we didn't see that one coming
what the satanists are saying
is that abortion is their
central sacrament
like we've been saying
for decades for decades peter craft
who's a wonderful uh theologian and
philosopher peter craft
put it very well a long time ago he said
quote abortion is the antichrist's
demonic parody of the eucharist this is
why it uses the same holy words this is
my body with the blasphemously opposite
meaning in
the christian communion the priest holds
up the eucharist and says this is my
body which will be given up for you
quoting christ
in
abortion the left says this is my body
this is my body my choice this even
though it isn't the woman's body it's
it's a little baby
so now all the dev what a devilishly
it's not clever it's we've we you don't
see it left you you can't understand
what you're doing
but we do see it
and a lot of people have seen this for a
long time
and even as you are now openly siding
with
satanists you don't understand
what you're doing
i'm so glad you liked that clip that
makes me feel very good if you wanted to
express your feelings about the clip
please leave me a comment below what i
really need you to do though to help us
get around a little bit of the
censorship that sometimes happens is
head on over to apple podcast spotify
stitch or google play wherever you get
your audio podcasts type in the michael
knowles show they're probably not even
gonna want it to come up to the top but
find it subscribe
maybe leave a five star review we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you